c'est fait depuis 1942 c'est là on est
aussi le bar qui se fait plus longtemps
qui a pignon sur rue sur un événement
voilà le vert bouteille a bénéficié des
prêts et subventions des gouvernements
mais pas sans embûches
on envoie tout ce qu'on a on attend deux
semaines pour avoir une réponse pour ce
faire
et ben ils manquent tel document puis
après ce rappel on peut bien vous avez
déjà le document oui mais on ne veut pas
de cette façon l'opinion
même son cloche du côté de la
discothèque du café campus on à faire
depuis cinquante trois ans ça nous a
beaucoup aidés ont été surpris après
cool de s'être élancé bureaucratique une
aide appréciée nécessaire mais trop peu
sollicité
on l'a reçu j'arrondis les chiffes le
2000 demandant à nos différents
programmes et j'aurais pu recevoir
finale au civil de mode
le programme des deux entreprises en
régions en alerte maximale a soutenu
1886 restaurant et 257 bars et
discothèques de la province depuis le
1er octobre
il ya des gens qui reprit des erreurs je
leur propre état il ya des gens qui
avaient les liquidités pour le faire et
peut-être des gens qui ont voulu
partager leurs données financières
le bar le belmont sur saint laurent
s'est vu refuser certaines subventions
alexandro craint que l'endettement de
l'emportent j'aimerais ça juste prendre
ma femme on allait mais quand tu as des
garanties personnelles qui sont liées au
bas et ben ça veut dire que si je mens
bobin
j'ai cent mille de garantie que je dois
quand même débourser juste pour mon
allait survivre jusqu'à la réouverture
mais aussi au delà quelques gourmandises
vous pouvez ouvrir on vous donne la
liberté mais vous pouvez pas avoir plus
que temps personne et qui est donc
contre la perte et en même temps que les
parents soient pull au québec a bonifié
son programme l'aide sera prolongé d'un
mois ou deux après la réouverture
cependant sans une reprise complète des
affaires ce délai pourrait être trop
court et les bars après tous ces efforts
pourraient devoir jeter la serviette ici
marie josée pas quelques mots radio
canada montréal